scattered in predominantly Jewish
communities the last two months have
proven that we have a long way to go in
making the world a safer place for our
Jewish brothers and sisters but we must
remember that the only way to drive out
darkness is to overwhelm it with light
and it is fitting today that we light
the capital manora which is a symbol of
the miracle of this holiday and a
celebration of course of the
rededication of the second temple and
the Triumph of the mccabes but we are
not just Illuminating the manur we are
display playing it proudly here in the
people's house for all of America's
viewing like so many Jewish families
have done in the windows of their homes
across the country I'm grateful to stand
beside these leaders who who deeply
value the free expression of religion in
our country and are committed to
fostering a culture that promotes the
flourishing of Jewish people and the
Jewish faith thank you for this
opportunity and may your candles burn
bright this season
leader thank you speaker and my
colleagues Rabbi Shmo for inviting us
hanukkah's a happy holiday so I thought
I'd first start off with a story and
then get into my remarks and it relates
to we were each given by Rabbi Shem TOA
yamaka so in 1992 I was redistricted
from my Brooklyn District to Queens into
a significant significantly Jewish
neighborhood and a lady came over to me
and said you're Congressman Schumer and
I said yes ma'am I am she said I've
never met you before but I watched
C-SPAN
religiously and I want to pay you a
compliment and I said Thank You Ma'am
she said of all the 435 members of the
Congress you have more courage than
anyone else I said well what do you mean
by that ma'am I know some of them we
call them no good Mi but some of them
are very good people what makes you say
I have more courage than any other she
said well as I said I've never met you
in person but I watch C-SPAN religiously
and when you rise to your feet to speak
you're the only one who has the courage
to wear a yamaka I said thank you ma'am
it's obvious you've never met me in
person it's not a
[Music]
yam
anyway on a more serious note uh we are
joined here by the bius family whose
family members are being held hostage in
Gaza at the brutal hands of Hamas
terrorists I want to thank everyone for
being here and for everything you and
other families are doing to advocate For
Your Precious loved ones we will not
stop until our efforts until every
hostage is released and returned home as
the highest ranking Jewish elected
official in America now and forever the
significance of a lighting manora here
in the capital is not lost on me it
reminds us of just how far the Jewish
people have come in our long and winding
history this year Hanukkah of course
comes at a moment of grief trial
and fear for the Jewish people and
perhaps for that it's all the more
meaningful in the darkness of our world
after the horrific attacks on Israel in
Israel on October 7th and amid the
dramatic and unfortunate spike in
anti-Semitism here in America we need
the light of Hanukkah more than ever
before the story of Hanukkah is a story
of perseverance in the face of
unspeakable hatred it's a story of how
the Jewish people of a different age
forced from their land forbidden to
practice their religion their Temple
destroyed and desecrated gathered to
pray in secret banded together in the
hills and Fields and fought off their
attackers once Victorious they set about
the hard the slow the painful work of
rededicating the temple and once again
lighting the Eternal Flame of Hope
rededication that is what those
survivors took part in by lighting the
candles that night that is what we are
all called to do this Hanukkah this
Hanukkah we must rededicate ourselves to
the promise of being a land of tolerance
for all people this Hanukkah we must
rededicate ourselves to standing against
anti-Semitism Islam phob islamophobia
and all other forms of bigotry and
discrimination it's why a few weeks ago
I went to the senate floor to speak
about the rise of anti-Semitism in
America I spoke out because as the
highest Jewish elected official in the
country I felt an obligation to say
aloud what is felt in the hearts of so
many Jewish people across the country
and around the world I shudder
absolutely shudder to think what it
would mean for the future of our
children and their children if
anti-Semitism continues to seep in our
society like a poison this Hanukkah we
must rededicate ourselves to building a
more perfect union one that preserves
equality equality for every American and
this Hanukkah we must rededicate
ourselves to building a more just and
equal world one in which democracy
thrives and prevails against the forces
of Darkness whether in Israel or in
Ukraine only after this rededication can
we begin the hard work of te te tun or
the repairing of the world this is a
noble but worthwhile request uh Quest
and we must all do our part so h a happy
Hanukkah to all of
[Applause]
you good afternoon
everyone thank you Rabbi
shent for being with us
today from the earliest days
Hanukkah was always been a Shining Light
in
darkness and for
Millennia the cruelties and injustices
of history have given the Jewish people
so many reasons to turn to this
celebration of
resilience and
endurance for
Generations you've drawn
inspiration from the Triumph of the m
year after
year you've turned with pride to the
manur as an enduring symbol of the
richness of Jewish culture and the depth
of Jewish
faith but I know for so many American
Jews this year
feels quite different this year the
darkness of that ancient form of
hatred
feels even darker
Israel is in
mourning and America Mourns with
her families are praying for the return
of innocent loved ones including several
Americans from
captivity and we're honored to welcome
one such family member who is with us
today but even in pain and grief the
people called a light unto the nations
are gathered to light candles
and ward off the
darkness once
again even now the Jewish people's
strength is a light in
itself so I'm honored to be with all of
you today to share in this
observance and to celebrate the miracle
of light and I join you in praying that
this light will penetrate the darkness
in which we live to bring about lasting
peace
happy
[Applause]
honor to speaker Johnson leader Schumer
leader McConnell all those assembled
happy
Hanukkah it's a high honor and distinct
privilege to be with you on today and
let me first just thank Rabbi shto for
uh his presence uh his spirit and for
helping to host this special Capitol
monoral Lighting the first of its kind
in the United States Congress and thank
you to the BBA family whose
cousins are being held hostage in Gaza
including 11 month old
kuir and his brother
Ariel your strength and advocacy are
inspiring and the release of all
hostages will continue to be our top
priority these are very difficult times
but the story of the Jewish people story
of the macbes and the story of Hanukkah
is one of
resilience of Hope in the face of
Oppression and of miraculous revolt
against tyranny
it's a story of
rededication not just of the desecrated
second
temple but rededication to fighting for
freedom fighting for
truth and fighting for
theight today in the spirit of Hanukkah
we rededicate ourselves to fighting for
these values we dedicate ourselves to
fighting for Freedom we dedicate
ourselves to fighting for the the Jewish
Community here in
Israel and all across the world we stand
together in the effort to crush
anti-Semitism anti-jewish
hatred and of course all forms of hatred
throughout this country and Beyond We
Stand Together to support Israel and to
make sure that in this great country of
ours America will always be a safe place
for the Jewish Community whether at
synagogue on campus at home or in the
neighborhood that is what the spirit of
Hanukkah teaches
us may God bless you may God bless the
Jewish community and may God continue to
bless the United States of America happy
[Applause]
Hanukkah
good afternoon happy
Kaneka is the
speaker Peter
Schumer Lita McConnell Lita
Jeff speaker amerit Nancy Pelosi and the
members who have come here to uh
celebrate with
us I um want to point out actually
that people tend to forget the
centrality of women in the existence of
the Jewish people and its miraculous
Odyssey when it came to definition in
the house of Abraham it was our
matriarch Sarah when it came to saving
Moses it was his
sister when it came to the story of
Purim it was Queen Esther and if you
read the history of Kaneka the actual
turning of the tide was through the
daughter of the high priest and I think
that um as a good son-in-law quote my
mother-in-law who says that when we talk
at the Passover seder V and that is
which has stood next to us the female
connotation of the Hebrew word is used
because she says V means the Jewish
woman so as uh I have the most important
Jewish woman in the world according to
me my wife in our presence I thought I'd
mention that
years ago in Billings Montana there was
a manura in someone's living room window
and somebody threw a rock through that
window the next day the newspaper
published a full page image of a manora
and urged everyone to put it in their
window in
solidarity there are only a few hundred
Jews in bildings maybe a thousand but
there were more than 10 or even
15,000 such windows with the newspaper
in their front
window this tells us that the cause of
Kaneka is a Jewish holiday but it's not
only a celebration for Jewish people the
victory of light over Darkness Justice
over Ty
tyranny uh ideas like these are
Universal so when I was asked the other
day at the national monora uh how many
family members of
hostages are here I said a couple
thousand how many are there generally
well in America 350 million in the world
7 billion because until the world is rid
of the disease of Hamas and all these
hostages are returned we are all of us
all of humanity in
captivity so I think that uh it's very
important to remember that while the
Jewish people people are most obviously
in pain all of America and all of the
world all decent meaning people as part
of the human race are all in
pain I just want to talk about the manur
for just a moment and before I say so
I'll say that the words diversity and
adversity have more or less the same
letters when diversity doesn't work out
we end up with adversity and we have to
put it all back together again and we
will this is a symbol of the Jewish
story of
resilience America is the story of
resilience and therefore when we like
the monora it's Jewish people keeping
our faith but I think it's a message we
can share with all our fellow Americans
and peoples around the world you're
going to notice that this there's one
candle that's not in a row with the
others that's called the shamash the
utility candle because at homes and in
situations which have more more space it
is used to light the other
candles the shamash is also indicative
of the public servant the one who gives
their life in the service of others
basically the people who fill this very
building and therefore all of us while
we have our lives of our own
illumination must find a way to
illuminate something Beyond ourselves
because the thing about light is it's
not like funds that when it's reduced to
help someone else there's less
when you light another candle the
original one is just as luminary so as a
human being if you help somebody else
you brighten their life you're not
losing anything they're gaining in which
case you're also gaining and if our
nation comes together and focuses on our
strengths even if we still retain our
opinions we'll only become a greater
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all which is
what we all live for here and and um I
want to of course acknowledge the family
uh members who are here of um of a baby
not even a year old who is in
captivity and uh that nonsense is just
intolerable so when we light the manora
we have to remember that this light will
also cure that darkness and we all pray
together each in our own way that God
Almighty will help us because a top the
Dome of this very
building and the words for the glory of
God and we all live for the glory of God
so whatever we do in here at the top of
the very Dome of this building those are
the words that tell us why we do it so
I'm going to tell you how we're going to
light it and then invite the leaders to
come and join me please and um I'll just
say a word of thanks to Senator Schumer
because this is his minur and he lent it
to us for this very celebration the
first of its kind I will tell you to
ever happen in the United States
especially in Congress Debbie wasman
Schultz who's here was the chairman of
the democratic party and L monora
together with Eric caner who was the
majority leader at the time in the house
but we've never had both leaders of both
houses together this is really a first
so please if we can come
[Music]
[Applause]
together now we're going to be making
two blessings and I want you to know
this is a
demonstration so when you light your own
manura and after we finish the manura
lighting please Avail yourselves of of
course lkas and donuts the traditional
Hanukah foods but also personal Hanukah
manora kits the way it works when you do
your own is you place them from right to
left and you uh light them with the
newest one first so I should actually be
on the other side but I don't want to do
that cuz it'll upset this photo but when
you do it at when you do it we slightly
differently those of you who know the
words can join me as soon as the music
[Music]
starts
[Applause]
for
[Music]
now many of you who are Jewish will do
this in your home for those who are not
of the Jewish faith might wonder what we
were just chanting I'll say it to you in
English first we said blessed are you
Lord our god king of the universe who
has given us the sanctity of his
mandates and Commandments and told us to
light these candles of KH the Second
Blessing was blessed are you Lord our
god king of the universe that has done
miracles for us and for our ancestors in
those days in these times and boy do we
need Miracles so please set it up those
who want to join us in one more uh tune
before the speaker will close the
[Music]
program
me b
[Music]
thank you for that and we'll have the S
gentlemen well thank you so much uh
Rabbi what a what a beautiful U Ceremony
this was we are grateful to everyone for
joining us for this expression of faith
and the celebration of the miracle of
Hanukkah God bless you all happy
[Applause]
Hanukkah
need